Hello everyone and welcome to another game you requested.
It's from the 1962 Curaçao Candidates Tournament.
We've already shown Pal Benko vs Bobby Fischer.
A very nice victory by Pal Benko with the Benko Opening or the Hungarian Opening, the 1. g3 move and
a lot of you said that you would like to also see his game against Mikhail Tal and
Well, let's just enjoy it. We haven't covered the 1962 Curaçao Candidates .
I'm planning to cover it at some point . Maybe as a part of the Tigran Petrosian Saga
as this is a candidates tournament that leads
to the World Chess Championship match, but maybe as a standalone tournament as it's such a nice tournament.
But until I decide on that, let's just enjoy this game.
So Benko with the white pieces again,
we have 1. g3 the Benko Opening 1... g6 2. Bg2 Bg7 3. d4
3... d6 4. e4 grabbing the center 4... Nf6
5. Ne2
5... O-O 6. O-O Nbd7 7. Nbc3
7... c6 8. a4. So the position is similar to the position Fischer had
against Benko, also in the in the Curaçao Candidates.
Although Fisher's knight was still on b8 and Fischer had a pawn on e5, but
what Fisher allowed was for Benko to push this pawn all the way to a5 whereas Tal doesn't allow it.
Tal pushes a5 himself and he says that it's
too strong to allow white to push a5.
So okay. 9. b3 similar like in the game against Fischer,
he wants to develop this bishop to a3 to assume this strong diagonal.
9... Re8 10. Ba3 Qc7 and it's interesting,
this position has never happened again after it was played in this game.
11. Qd2 preparing to connect rooks and only now 11... e5 now that he really controls the e-file.
But, of course,
Benko ignores it. 12. Rad1 exd4 13. Nxd4
13... Nc5. Tal finds an excellent outpost for this knight on c5
as white will be unable to push b4 due to the a5 pawn Tal pushed and also white doesn't have a d-pawn to
kick it away and it's very unlikely that you will give up your dark square bishop for this knight.
So an excellent outpost for the knight. 14. f3 strengthening the e4 pawn
14... b6 Tal is now ready to develop the light square bishop as well. 15. Nde2
Now the queen and rook are ready to capture on d6.
So Tal has to defend in some way. Now you could defend it with 15... Rd8
But Tal is greedy. Tal says I already developed this rook to e8
I want to play Bb7 maybe Ba6 and bring this rook over to
d8 without wasting any time so first he defends it with the 15... Bf8.
But now with Bf8 this bishop no longer controls this excellent diagonal. So Benko transfers his own Bishop
to this excellent diagonal.  16. Bb2
16... Qe7. This is an odd move.
I haven't really
seen the idea behind Qe7
Bb7 followed by Rad8 as he planned seems to be the way to go but
he prefers Qe7. And Benko takes this opportunity to get his knight into the game 17. Nd4
17. Kf4 was also a possibility, but he plays Kd4 as the queen no longer guards the c6 pawn
But this doesn't really bother Tal as he was planning to develop the bishop to b7 either way. 17... Bb7 and now
The knight also blocks the queen's attack towards the d6 pawn.
So Tal doesn't have to worry about that.
18. Rfe1 Bg7. Now the bishop can get back to this strong diagonal as the pawn is
not in danger of being captured. 19. f4 Rad8. Tal manages to
get his a rook to d8 as planned. 20. Bf3 now controlling
the g4 square not allowing the black knight to go there and also
making room for the king or the queen to occupy the g2 square. 20... Qd7
and now if you don't want to allow some Qh3 ideas, Benko prevents it with 21. Qg2 d5
Tal would be very happy if he can just trade everything on d5
Make his light square bishop come alive, but Benko of course is not interested in that.
He says we're just gonna keep the center closed.
22. e5 pushing the knight back 22... Nfe4
and now it seems like Tal is offering a pawn
but he's really not. Benko trades once 23. Nxd4 dxe4 and now even though it seems like he can capture here,
he really can't because if 24. Bxe4 Nxe4. It doesn't really matter what you capture the knight with.
Let's say 25. Qxe4 c5 just wins the game as now you either lose the queen, of course
you're gonna move the queen, but then you lose the knight, so you're gonna be down a piece.
So after 23... dxe4 Benko doesn't fall for it.
He plays 24. Be2 Qe7, getting the queen away from this d file as it's just
not really doing all that much here. And now Benko brings the bishop back 25. Ba3
So really nice maneuvering with the bishop by Benko.
First a3 then returning to b2 when the b2 diagonal became more important then now returning it
to a3 pinning the knight As Tal's queen is now on e7. And here Tal probably should have gone 25... Qc7.
Even on the previous move Qc7 was better.
Just so Ba3 doesn't do anything.
But even here just retreating with Qc7 is best. But here
Tal played 25... f6. Now is this one of those positions where it's actually okay to play f6?
You will decide as you will pause the video here and try to find the best continuation for Benko in this position.
Well, I give you a couple of seconds
So for those of you who were able to do it,
congratulations, you are an excellent punisher of an f6 move when it's not okay to play it in a position.
And for those of you who just want to enjoy the show 26. Bc4+. And now, of course, you see that you cannot
interpose with the knight as the knight is pinned, you will lose the queen.
You cannot go Kf8 because just Ne6+ pretty much ends the game.
So Tal played 26... Kh8
27. Ne6 just the same as the knight still cannot be captured due to the pin.
You have to move the rook the problem is
once this dark square bishop gets eliminated and it will be eliminated this bishop will once again return to this square
and then Benko will have these... Well, we can say it, a nice bishop pair from hell.
27... Rd5 Tal decided it was better just to give up the rook that way. For example
if you play something like 27... Rxd1 28. Rxd1, then
there's not a good move once Nxg7.
You're just gonna bring the Bb2 you're gonna capture on f6 open up this diagonal and it's just game over.
So Tal decided to give up the the exchange with 27... Rd5 to at least get rid of one of the bishops.
So Benko said, okay. It's a nice rook. I will have it.
28. Bxd5 cxd5 and now of course you are getting rid of the dark square bishop. 29. Nxg7
29... Kxg7 30. exf6+ Qxf6
not allowing Bb2 as the queen now guards the b2 square, but it's not a problem 31. Qf2
You don't want to allow something like e3 and d4
for Tal to free his bishop. 31. Qf2 not allowing e3 31... Ne6. Now Tal,
he's down the exchange, but he does have a strong center and if he can push d4 and e3
and if this bishop comes alive, it could become very dangerous for Benko.
So here Tal is saying basically, well bluffing actually, that Benko cannot capture on b6, that it's too dangerous.
But Benko says I'm not tricking you. I know your style
I'm just gonna capture it because this is a nice free pawn.
So he played 32. Qxb6 and now, of course, Tal has to do something about the bishop.
32... Ba8 33. Bd6
Benko is now preparing Be5 to win the queen here.
So Tal just gets the queen out of the way. 33... Qf5
Now already again if Tal can get these two moves in then the bishop, the queen there might be something here
But 34. Bxa5. Benko just grabs another pawn. He says there's nothing there.
Tal moves the king even further to safety. 34... Kh6 35. c4
starting to push the pawns because if you capture then just a nice queen trade.
But as Benko is up in material Tal cannot afford a queen trade. 35... Rd8
Attacking the bishop, 36. Be7 attacking the rook and also preparing Bg5 if needed.
This will come with check. So Tal says okay here
it's all or nothing. 36... e3. Tal just pushes the pawn and he asks are you maybe interested in a nice rook on d8?
Well, could you capture it? Sure, you could capture it. There isn't all that much poison there but there's no need
to give Tal more than you need because a lot of players did this and, you know, it always goes wrong.
37. Rxe3 just getting rid of that pawn and getting the rook to a more useful square.
37... Re8. The rook overstayed its welcome on d8, 38. Bg5+.
Of course any trades are not in your favour. Now the rook on e8 is unguarded
38... Kg7 39. Bde1 Benko claims the e-file for himself.
And again Tal says it's all or nothing. 39... Nxg5. Tal tries giving up the rook on e8
For some Nf3 action and even though you could capture it allow 40... Nf3+, it's really hard to do
to actually blunder the game. Even if something like 41.Kg2 Nxe1+ 42. Rxe1
You deliver this check in hopes of picking up the queen on a5 it doesn't worry because just 43. Qxa8 so it's
very hard to blunder this game. But you're playing against Tal you don't want to
complicate it too much. So he just played 40. fxg5 Rf8
So Tal now has decent pressure along the f-file and if he manages to free the light square bishop,
Tal maybe could do something but Benko here played 41. Qa7+
and in fact it was in this position that Mikhail Tal resigned the game on move 41
as there really is nothing more to do here.
Because once the king moves you can't go here now,
the pawn is guarding that square you have to go to g8 or h8 doesn't really matter.
41... Kh8. If you block with the rook, of course, you lose the bishop with check.
So 41... Kh8
42. Re7 and there's no defense. Just Rxh7 is coming and
with the queen on a7 you also guard the f2 square. So you can't even do a
nice little check on f2.
So yeah, I think I'm gonna use this as a thumbnail as it's really nice.
But yeah a very nice victory by Pal Benko defeating Fischer, defeating Tal. He also beat Paul Keres in this tournament.
So it was a very nice tournament for Benko. And like I said at one point we will cover the 1962 Curaçao Candidates Tournament.
Either as a part of the Tigran Petrosian Saga or as a standalone tournament, we're gonna we're gonna see how it goes.
But yeah, that's the game. I do hope you enjoyed it and I would like to apologize for not mentioning
it was a mate in 3 in the previous video. That's the price you pay for not showing all that many puzzles.
It just completely slipped my mind, but you know...
Looking on the bright side of things, you know, it's very unlikely that I will make such a mistake again.
So that's that's a plus I guess
But yeah, like I said, that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it.
I would like to thank Emily Boyce, Gabriel Frechette., Ryan Stevenson, Daniel Moyer and Vinso Shinabery for a contribution to my channel
Thank you a lot. I really appreciate it. As usual, you can check two of my previous videos here.
Thank all for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the Capablanca Saga.
We are now going after that and we're going to finish it and then just checking up on your suggestions
and of course whatever happens in the chess world
So thank you all I will see you soon and have an excellent rest of your day!